Today, we got ourselves a package space, force dollars.
I got interested in these.
When I saw an ad on YouTube that was advertising space
force $2 bills, and they swore it was legal Tinder.
Did this war was legal for 10 space for dollars.
You know how much it costs a hundred dollars for $10. Here it is.
Ladies and gentlemen, the space force $2 bill.
There's no way anyone accepts this.
Now I just want to jump in here because you might be wondering, well,
is it legal? Is this a legal bill? And the answer is, I don't know. We,
according to the, the private company who did this,
this is not the government who printed this.
This is a regular $2 bill that a private company has like colorized
on top of it with some non-destructive film or something like that.
I don't really understand it, but that has to have its limitations, right?
Like this just looks ridiculous. And I want to know will people actually,
we're going to go to a bunch of fast food restaurants and, uh,
check who has been bought out by the Chinese.
And who's still American will order something from a, their dollar menu.
Try to pay with a $2 bill. We'll see who does it,
who accepts it and who doesn't. I'm excited. I don't think anyone,
if I had to guess, I'll try about five places today.
I doubt anyone will accept it. Instead.
I think we're going to find out that the a hundred dollars I spent was a
complete waste of time. And, uh, I have gotten scammed. Oh,
we've got a Wendy's here. I'll just take a small frosty, please.
Hi, do you guys take space for us dollars?
You.
They told me it was legal, legal Tinder. Genuine.
Donald told me it was real. They like colorize the $2 bill.
I mean, I guess we can, we just don't get a lot of $2 bills. No worries. Thanks.
Wendy's 10 out of 10 patriotic confirmed baby.
I am totally shocked. That felt.
Too easy. Hey, I'm.
Johnny space farce. That's it.
That's all there is to it up next.
We have McDonald's I think handing them the Trump thing got them last time.
I like if I had to think psychologically, I think that overloaded them.
You don't get handed a certificate of authenticity from Donald Trump very often.
So very interesting. How do you guys accept the a space force? $2 bill.
Hold on. Sure.
Boy. Hey, by the way, if you need it, I got a certificate of authenticity here.
I think he likes this.
Donald's going to be very happy. Thank you. This is not going.
I thought, I thought nobody would accept this.
I saw someone here. Would you like would like space force dollars?
I've got $2 bill and space for us dollars.
Seriously. It's a type of $2 bill.
Do you want it? Yeah. It's real money. You just have to show them.
This is Sean. This think that yeah, absolutely. God bless you.
Saving America one space, horse dollar at a time.
That'd be honest. Driving home. I felt conflicted. On the one hand,
I was shocked that people accepted the money. On the other hand,
I wonder how much my own persuasion played into that. Like I wondered,
could I have just taken monopoly money and just been like, Hey, take it,
take it, Hey and hand them some stupid, you know,
fake certificate of authenticity. Because again,
this is not like from the president, right?
They just literally have Donald Trump on their little thing that they send with
it. And it says 45th president of the United States, which sure is true.
But it, it implies that this is like some presidential bill,
which it's not. And so I wondered how much that had to do with it.
So I decided to call around instead and kind of remove that personal element,
remove this from the equation as like a way to persuade them and
really just make it about, you know, does it make sense to accept a space force,
$2 bill? Do you guys accept, uh, the new space force,
$2 bill.
And then the currency that is usually tendered, right?
Yeah. But it's got it's the new space force, like kind of logo.
I know some people accept it. Some people don't like Donald Trump,
I think probably would accept it. But, um, given that there's, you know,
the new presidency, that's all been kind of called into question, you know, the,
you know, I don't know if Joe.
All right, give me one moment. Let me, okay. Cool.
You said it's space force.
Yeah. It's the new space force. $2 bill it's printed by the Merrick mint.
They're a private mint. Like, like I think if Trump got elected again,
it'd probably be legal Tinder, but now I'm not so sure with Joe Biden's,
I'm trying to spend, I spent a lot of money on these $2 bills.
Cause I thought they might be worth something,
but now I'm trying to spend them before Biden gets into office.
You know how he is with like China and you know, you're paying him.
I get you. I'm just trying to figure out if we accept it.
You should see it. They've got like a, they've got like a spaceship on it.
They've got like a rocket going to the moon. Um, it's a pretty cool bill.
I think think pizza hut would be happy to happy to.
All right. So she's saying we only accept the regular recognize though.
You do not accept the United States space force $2 bill.
She, what she said to me is the killer recognized,
but what I'm trying to explain to her, what it is say has a spaceship on it.
On it. It's uh, it's got a satellite. Uh,
I don't know how else to describe it.
As long as pizza hut bent it probably before Joe Biden got into office,
I think it'd probably be fine, but, um, I am a little bit worried that this,
this currency will be useless after, you know,
the socialist gets in the white house. I'm a little bit worried about.
So what I do suggest though you can,
when you get to the store, see if they accepted at the store.
But you're saying that they probably won't though, is what you're saying.
Cause I don't want to drive down there with all my I've got like a duffel bag of
space.
What accepted and there shouldn't be a reason why they would not accept it
because if it's printed to be used in the country, then.
Patriotic to not, not take it. Right.
Like I feel like that would be almost unpatriotic.
It is a United States space force.
Unless like the name has changed from the space force.
I wouldn't say it's a part of patriotic or not it's whether or not
they bashed us because it, the knowledge isn't there.
Then the utterance is going to be there as well.
Right? Yeah. The ignorance is there. I think they wouldn't take it, but well,
okay. I'll drive right into the store. I mean,
if that's what it takes to get this, this space for us dollars off my hands.
Okay, great. Thank you. Alrighty. Thank you. Bye. All right.
So this is going to be a bit of a different test guys.
This is going to be a Starbucks chat thing because so far we've gone in person.
We got them. We called pizza hut. We got them.
Now I want to know will Starbucks do it? So I'm asking them a question.
Starbucks accepting space force. $2 bill. Question of patriotism.
First name Ben, last name, Dover. It looks like we got dagger. Okay.
Hi dagger.
D does Starbucks currently accept space
$4?
Maybe we should attach like a picture of the space force dollar I've attached to
the currency. In question, I heard you guys were having a war with Christmas,
but I'm sure Howard feels differently about space force. Then I appreciate that.
You're trying to confirm if we accept space force $2,
I'm going to start attaching more files.
Should I hit them with the certificate of authority? No.
One's been able to resist the certificate of authority guys.
I don't have that information available,
but I will be happy to find any updates for you. Well,
it seems like a simple question of patriotism.
To be honest,
I understand that the socialists think Donny,
I sound so unhinged right now. Donny is out of office,
but we've got,
I think space force bills should be allowed through.
Let's pull him into this.
I think space force bills should be allowed who at least the end of
Donald's presidency, don't you.
And then let's hit them with the certificate of authenticity. Here we go.
We hit them with the certificate of authenticity. At this time.
What I can do is share your thoughts with the team in charged useless.
Also I would invite you to post your idea@ideasdotstarbucks.com.
Most of the ideas posted here I've already come to.
I'm not suggesting anything though.
Simply ask if I bring in my $2 base for
spill, if they will give me my grand day,
you're more than welcome to try Ben. At this time,
there is no restriction are any updates about accepting this type of current
sank?
You dagger D I will be sure to note among my
fellow Patriots,
that Starbucks hasn't sold out to China just yet.
So to recap, I think Starbucks was probably the worst least likely to accept,
but in this case, I guess least likely to accept does not necessarily mean bad.
Maybe more like diligent. Wow. So this is a weird twist.
I was about to finish this video and I teased it on social media and somebody
from within the business reached out to me saying that they'd love to share some
insider tips. So this is my call with him.
We learned how much money they're making.
Here's that talk as a little capstone to this goofy video.
Do you see that you guys.
Yup. We made that ad. That's what? A hundred percent we at the,
I have like the made-up like screenshots of the cutouts of Trump that I have is
like hilarious.
So how much money are you making with this? I mean, I I've got,
I never fall for ads. I understand.
You got to understand you're the first person who got me.
I had never fought for this stuff. I saw it. I said, it's too good.
They win the marketers finally win. How so? Yeah. What are we talking about?
Here?
There you go. It is good. So like, so the cost of goods for that bill.
So for us to get the bill, package it,
ship it out to you like that dollars a specific bill, um, for,
um, for us in particular, it's in the $7 range. So for others,
it could be anywhere from like nine 12, or like whatever,
like relationship you have with the manufacturer.
But if you buy it directly from them directly, they'll sell it to you for about,
think about 15 bucks. Oh,
but you guys have a wholesale deal. They're actually just drop shipping.
So we're shipping directly from the manufacturer. So it's not even wholesale.
Dang it. I've been telling people, drop shipping doesn't work.
Okay.
How much you make it with this business here, Brian.
So like, just to make it clear, I'm an employee of the business.
We're hitting the thought about like 7.5 mil. Yeah.
Revenue.
Hang on Brian. That can't all be profit, but I do know a large,
maybe larger profit margin than people think,
because if you're getting it for seven bucks, it is, it's pretty high margin.
You guys charged me a freaking grip for this. I've been salted.
I had to pay like 20 bucks for that.
But obviously this has to be your best year.
It being the election and everything. And does it kind of dry up after this,
I guess, or do you switch to selling Biden merchant? I mean,
does Biden March sell? I don't know.
So what's funny is that we selling like left leaning stuff
multiple times and it flops like my boss when he was on eight did for Haley
completely flopped.
They'll give her two smacks about like Hillary or like Democrat party, whatever.
But the minute we go conservative, it just, they just throw money at it.
It's wild, like for the Biden. And um,
like we have our own bills. We try, you know,
putting it through Facebook ads is just a complete waste of money, you know?
We're like, all right, we tried.
Just that it's Trump or is it that it's like cleaning right-leaning thing?
I honestly, I think it's just like a, more of like a,
I think just when it comes to online and selling, I think it's just like, like,
uh, like conservatives just in general,
like I just assume they just have more money and, and like,
they're more passionate about not like Trump and like,
and like in their beliefs. So like,
it's really easy to sell that Patriot TISM to them.
Our next hottest drop is Trump's still our president and that's our way to bill
like him like fighting back. So he's like still our president.
Oh my God. Yeah. Hold on. I'll show you. Okay. It's okay.
Oh my gosh, dude. These are outrageous.
These are outrageous. All right, man. Well, uh,
I'm going to leave it at that this video is not sponsored, so not sponsored,
so I don't want to do a whole pitch fast, but uh, it's uh,
think you'll forgive guys.
Goofy gift for the fam you guys crazy uncle at Thanksgiving.
You ought to make happy. Hey,
stole my president $2 bill may be just the thing anyways,
guys. Um, I'll see you next time. Thanks.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.